esta escuela del centro de kabul es
exclusivamente para niñas la educación
se imparte desde la primaria hasta la
secundaria pero desde que los talibanes
se tomaron el poder las niñas mayores de
12 años no pueden ir a la escuela para
estos alumnos de primer grado el plan de
estudios no ha cambiado esa mañana
después de las matemáticas estudian el
corán
que leemos hoy
los versículos del corán buscó refugio
en dios contra satanás
[Música]
la llegada al poder de los
fundamentalistas religiosos amenazan los
sueños de sus hijas
les dijimos que las otras chicas
volverían pronto ellos sentirán lo que
pasa nosotros tampoco aún así las
animamos a seguir su camino porque el
futuro es suyo
vengo a la escuela y estudian mis
lecciones quiero ser médica y cuidar a
la gente que está enferma pero después
del sexto grado los talibanes no nos
permiten seguir estudiando y eso me
entristece
las profesoras de secundaria están
desocupadas acuden a la escuela todos
los días a pesar de que sus alumnas han
sido expulsadas del centro
impartía las clases aquí en estas aulas
que están a ambos lados del pasillo
antes de la caída estos pasillos estaban
siempre llenos de chicas adolescentes me
molesta que nuestras aulas estén vacías
se nos rompe el corazón cuando pensamos
en eso nuestros alumnos están en casa
sin hacer nada podrían perder todo lo
que han aprendido hasta ahora es
desgarrador
en algunas provincias los gobernadores
locales permiten a las escolares
continuar su educación pero en kabul los
talibanes no han dado 'luz verde' por lo
que en la capital están surgiendo clases
informales como en este barrio popular
por razones de seguridad difuminamos los
rostros de las chicas y de su
improvisado profesor un brillante
estudiante de 19 años hace seis semanas
con el acuerdo de sus padres formó este
pequeño grupo para que ella y sus amigos
no retrocedieran en su educación
el río helmand es el más largo de
afganistán con más de 1400 kilómetros de
longitud
bien genial me morí salud para mañana te
haré un examen
extrañas la escuela
hay alguien en el mundo a quien no le
gusta la escuela por supuesto la echo
mucho de menos
que estas chicas se reúnen todas las
tardes algunas son muy jóvenes y podrían
haber vuelto a la escuela pública no lo
hacen por miedo
no puedo ir porque hay muchos talibanes
en el camino y me dan miedo no me
encuentro con ninguno para venir aquí
por eso vengo acá
es una escuela secreta porque aparte de
los padres de estas chicas que vienen a
estudiar aquí nadie más sabe lo que
hacemos los talibanes no saben nada al
respecto si se enterarán no sé cómo
reaccionarían ya que algunas de sus
hijas no pueden ir a la escuela
los funcionarios talibanes aseguran que
la escolarización de las niñas se
reanudará en todo el país
no queremos que nuestras mujeres
conozcan solo la religión necesitamos
mujeres médicas ingenieras funcionarias
pero tienen que ser buenas musulmanas al
igual que los hombres las mujeres son la
mitad de nuestra sociedad y queremos que
se eduquen una educación sin embargo
conforme los principios islámicas
el emirato islámico de afganistán emana
de un movimiento islámico y el objetivo
de nuestros 20 años de yihad era
establecer un sistema político basado en
la sharía
que respetar a nuestros principios
religiosos y culturales afganos no
podemos comprometer todo esto bajo la
presión de la comunidad internacional
en las oficinas de esta emisora de radio
local las mujeres siguen trabajando pero
han sido necesarios algunos ajustes
colocamos estas cortinas y esta carpa
blanca encima de nuestras cabezas para
aislarnos de estas escaleras y así estar
completamente separadas del espacio de
trabajo de los hombres
si tenemos un permiso del ministerio de
información y cultura para ellos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
difundimos este tipo de poesía religiosa
que glorifica al profeta y adiós estos
son los únicos géneros musicales que
podemos emitir ahora
dentro de su programación la emisora de
emite un programa educativo para que las
mujeres afganas que se han visto
privadas de la escuela puedan seguir
aprendiendo dentro de sus casas el
ministerio de información también ha
aprobado un programa de salud y apoyo
psicológico las mujeres un rayo de
esperanza en el país de los talibanes